[Applaudissements]
très bien ces messieurs ont même est
parti en sucette
abbas et josé mal de mcginn a dit ranger
risques vous avez dit pour les nems mère
faisait des nems faisait pas ça mais
leur maison lembras d'ailleurs madame
lemoine thérèse thérèse lemoine j adore
bricoler très vietnamien est ce que moi
sur la tête de ma mère on dirait une
héroïne de tf1 bonjour vous n'aurez
jamais mes terres madame lemoine vous
divaguez c'est peut-être reviendront au
mériadeck vous le vouliez ou non à sa
belle soeur thérèse lemoine ça va allez
merci très drôle vous êtes plus drôle en
visuel sur du visuel personnes c'est
rare sinon en pleine forme basse et
merci il est drôle en gif le très drôle
augis question oui mathieu oui bien sûr
accidental on va tous nous raconter mais
je vous jure c'est raconter un truc qui
m'a qui m'a bouleversé
non mais vraiment ouais je raconterai
mon match et ça va vous sinon très
mignon jean luc tu peux faire ta
chronique et inclut même y arriver à 70
c est comment ça va est ce que tu veux
tout le temps que je ne pas se voir oui
très mignon mais il nous a tous
inquiétés quelque chose que je voulais
dire parce que c'est ça ma va alors je
dis je pleure tout le temps mais de joie
mais un truc qui m'a beaucoup beaucoup
touché je crois que sans exception à
d'ailleurs sans exception de tous les
gens de tpm paiement envoyé un petit
texto saint-louis sushis
mais
merci
ian moderne il ya le soufflé dans
l'oreille soit il m'a dit vous êtes tous
là non si ma mise à bagad cette conne
tiens j'adore jambes à neuf et c'est
vrai tout le monde tout le monde mon
numéro
mais les autres et tout le monde tout le
monde vous êtes beaucoup en plus et
c'est vrai et même je vous jure pour
vous dire même isabelle lui envoyer un
fax à les questions tout de suite
bonjour je m'appelle marie
on a parfois l'impression que c'est
tendu entre les membres de l'équipe donc
je voulais savoir est ce une impression
ou au contraire faites vous souvent
l'amour tous ensemble on n'a pas envie
d'attraper des maladies
vous savez qu'il ya des maladies ici
quoi non je sais pas à part bordeaux
revit un bilan médical de chacun oui je
comprends cette question chère marie mai
mais non nous ne faisons jamais l'amour
tous ensemble c'est juste par petits
groupes et par affinité et pas
d'obligation contractuelle mais je
comprends vous puissiez penser que la
détention car la semaine dernière une
séquence des cafetières à semer le
trouble
on la revoit
béthune
m
obama là bas ma faim
jours un membre du public me demande est
ce que vous pouvez faire venir mathieu
j'ai un truc à lui dire j'appelle
mathieu et mathieu n'est jamais venu
nancement fiche
ah oui voilà ça fait quand même battu à
ce que c'est vrai immense île mais
prévenu cette jeune fille est tout
mignon je serais tu te dis lui faire un
bisou
alors j'ai cherché il est malade et je
dois faire mon bien qu'ils passent
justement il est malade je me suis
emballé c'est mathieu qui avait raison
je pensais que j'avais des images mais
en fait non dakar était bien un
inventeur
voilà donc je vais faire mon mea culpa
excuse moi d'avoir douté toi mathieu à
sa mère c'est trop minuscule de maxime
alors excusé ou maxime l excuse je n'ai
vraiment vécu dans les nerfs que tu as
menti
non non je vais vraiment wegelin mais
non mais je déconne depuis tout à
l'heure ce qui s'est vraiment passé il
ya quelques semaines
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il va y aller c'est du connu depuis un
accident il a changé tout et soeurs mis
en place cet été l'ancien matin co2 j'ai
encore d'autres images de l'ancien matin
on va en faire le deuil d'un ton passer
le temps sur mathieu c'était un modèle
regarder envisage donc quoi ça la vie a
changé c'est l'ancien as well mathieu
qui n'est pas la notoriété l'argent et
tous les livres mais vie pourquoi m'avez
plus d'argent pour l'amour les rend con
way maintenant des maladies d'accord
merci mais tu entends ces médicaments
ajouté
[Rires]
la semaine dernière tout cas personne
ils disent et ce qu'ils devaient faire
et surtout pas le patron cyril hanouna
aura le dieu du soleil dans l'ancienne
egypte parce que la semaine dernière je
pas si vous souvenez on recevait les
bodin's surnom à mathieu la balayette
ah oui juste avant l'accident voilà
c'est ça mais oui c'était y'a pas de
lien de cause à effet entre la balayette
et l'accident ils ont eu la chance les
bodin's que ce soit passé parce que ce
jour-là il était remonté comme j'ai
rarement vu mathieu larouche de nerfs il
était prêt à éclater cyril au moindre
petit écart et vous noterez au passage
en l'écoutant qu'apparemment le maître à
penser de mathieu c'est pas victor hugo
c'est jean claude van damme extrêmes on
a pu parler quand je pars toujours
d'accord
j'ai fait ma carrière j'ai fait ma route
et my way
toi c'est pas tenir comme ça et là
attention à mon jugement
ok
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je fais c'était le surnom que vous avez
donné les védas ça c'était avant
why they have anciens maths et pour le
plaisir pour faire le deuil de l'ancien
mcgregor écoute même pour moi la phrase
de la semaine
j'ai fait ma carrière
[Musique]
ouais ok il est fou ce mec c'est jean
claude van damme aux éclats alors je
vous rassure il n'y a pas que des
tensions dans l'équipe aille au seae des
magnifiques moments d'entre aide par
exemple en cas de coup dur on sait qu'on
peut compter sur jean michel maire à qui
je vous le rappelle parce qu'on a
tendance à l'oublier a été reporter de
guerre de guerre oui bien sûr il a dû en
vivre des situations déficit aider des
gens blessés autour de lui qu'il devait
prêter secours
ouais ça a l'air de rien mais comme ça
mais quand quelqu'un a un petit problème
de santé il peut réagir jean michel
merci jean mi
c'est tout
j'ai mal à nous
[Applaudissements]
avant mai
un conteur chanteur de guerre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
un reporter de guerre au carré oscille à
l'acropole achim calibre d'écloserie
demain c'est pour vous dire la cause de
jean louis je suis allé chez le dentiste
le lendemain parce qu'il m'a éclaté
alors mes bobos sous la dent jaunie
faire mal non mes briquets non messieurs
non mais il m'a fait super mal j'ai fait
je me suis excusé
j'étais curé barbu aussi merci voilà non
ça va mieux depuis depuis ça va très bon
joueur il a passé commande à l'image
somme serait est ce que voulaient des
petits moments bizarres sur régal
n'auront pas cet objet danse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce jeudi j'ai surgi le sait pas la
girouette qui tourne c'est le vent s'est
s'avéré sont assez intelligents sont
[Musique]
donnés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais te dire un truc s'était jamais
vu un aussi bon dans l'émission
[Applaudissements]
en effet j'ai figé tard
les montres
c'est maladroit
[Musique]
un quiz de culture générale qui se passe
sur douze questions
chaque question à 12 réponses on te pose
une question à la fin de la question il
ya deux invités et une personne lambda
qui joue juste avant qu'on propose des
réponses pour qu'on fait une partie de
bowling
on lance de moules on supprime beaucoup
de nos baisses de coûts
on accueille une personne lambda karen
et qui va essayer avec ses cinquante
mille euros de réaliser 100 m et surtout
je vous regarde sur l'île et pas
commencé par dire un jeu à une
assistance en une phrase
j'étais sur les répète aujourd'hui
c'était vrai ça va être très fort a way
you lie et il a été très bon vincent il
explique les règles trésor qu'il est
d'une clarté sur le jeu franchement
autant moi quand j'ai vu quelque chose
dans lui c'est que c'est un pitre
voilà on s'est régalé l'axé appellent
mania la belle complètement sûr on a
l'impression qu'elle écoute je vois un
truc c'est que vous vous déplacez magath
et vous les deux jeux plus vous mettre à
côté
ah oui mais on commençait baisse
commence à bien sa prévoyait justement
justement un moyen vaut mieux vous
séparer merci il aime pas qu on s'entend
très bien
la semaine dernière un autre grand
événement nous recevions l'équipe de
taxi 5 avec nous a permis de voir cyril
sous un nouveau jour
déjà on a découvert quelque chose qu'on
ignorait sa pudeur car autant il peut se
mettre un poulpe dans slip et beaucoup
de facilité autant il est effrayé par un
simple bisou sur la bouche
au loin il était très gentil
oh non non on regarde regarde et le
malaise du garçon et surtout comment
hors antenne
il verra la seconde c'est un petit
secret de fabrication de tpm
j'aime beaucoup natacha et si vous
faisait un bisou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est chez nous on va se retrouver dans
un jeu reviendra sur laeticia hallyday
et sébastien farran qui est donc le
manager de jonah est en garde à vue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et très gentil elle est très anti au
passage la comédienne que vous avez
appelé d'acquisition on attache à
natacha tu es même sabrina un moment sa
place ici c'est un détail la mesquinerie
la tâche at c'est vrai dormir drôle très
drôle et là maintenant une de mes vidéos
préférées de la semaine est la
mesquinerie connais bien pas vu venir et
on la doit à malik bentalha s'il a fait
il était très embêté car le soir-même
sais pas si vous vous souvenez il passé
dans l'émission de frédéric lopez sur
les notaires nos terres inconnues et
face à lui en frontal sur m6 élevé cyril
chez stéphane plaza travail je passais
deux minutes ouais mais mais quand même
quand cyril a fait la promotion de
maisons à vendre
malik essayer de faire comprendre que
les spectateurs devraient plutôt le
regarde et lui c'est mignon parce que tu
sens qu'il assume pas trop du coup
personne ne l'entend bricolages home des
collettes bricoler temps
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça te tais je la connais tellement comme
as la connais par coeur cette équipe est
alors taxi sans éclat filet important
puisqu'il marque aussi les noms débuts
au cinéma de matthieu delormeau
ouais bah on va pas refaire toute
l'histoire mais vous savez mathieu avait
année franck gastambide pour faire
partie du cast avec un succès très
relatif
mais comme il ne renonce jamais quand il
a vu rentrée luc besson sur le plateau
la semaine dernière c'est comme s'il
avait vu le père noël est ce que
voulaient voir le moment où la carrière
de mathieu dans le cinéma a basculé
alors c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai pas blessé
non
[Musique]
après
on a appris le magnéto qui cotait comme
reste encore un non résident annoncé
réglé oui ça oui qu'est-ce qui se passe
un à un ils allaient l'hérault chez
numéro de gel mais de jean n b
[Rires]
non
je crois que c'est toujours des gens de
l'est jean luc besson est vraiment
tenter pourquoi pas oublié bien tenté
avec un mathurin star il a réussi et
pourquoi ça marcherait pas d'accord vous
avez vous dire toi là on commence par un
teasing qui avait fait syrie d'avoir une
pub
il nous expliquait que quelqu'un qu'on
connaissait bien avait participé à
l'émission de sophie davant affaire
conclue ouais mais il nous avait pas
donné le nom j'aime beaucoup les yeux
ouverts parfaite comme je voulais
vraiment
[Musique]
non
autre but dans sa chambre elle fait pas
mes cheveux sont implantées en fonction
d'implantation donc on mets les plus
fins devant les plus épais derrière donc
c'est vrai mais derrière on retrouve les
sections frisé avec sa fanfare paris
marseille en deux heures et ce en cours
oui comme ça
les bureaux de vote
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette nouvelle donne avec cette histoire
d'instagram
bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces compagnies qui est bon pour chamakh
a donné un bien quoi tu ressembles à tes
autres grâce à wii d'être moche
s'amusant avec julie gayet la fameuse
affaire du scooter moi je suis pour une
transparence et j'ai bouffé le coup je
bouffais
applaudissements polis
[Applaudissements]